j'en tire les conclusions en me retirant
de la vie politique je crois que c'est
après des déclarations
[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler de
théorie politique d'ernesto laclos et
chantal manche si ces deux noms ne vous
disent rien sachez qu'ils sont les
inspirateurs de podemos en espagne et de
jean luc mélenchon en france jusqu'en
2014 leur théorie était très peu connue
chez nous mais avec l'émergence du parti
anti austérité espagnol certains
intellectuels de la gauche française se
sont penchés sur les écrits de leurs
inspirateurs pour tenter de comprendre
et de reproduire leur succès électoral
c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui cette théorie
servent de référence à une partie
d'entre eux ainsi si vous avez regardé
france 24 le 26 janvier 2017
vous êtes peut-être tombé sur cette
séquence emmanuel macron c'est le
signifiant vide pour un certain nombre
d'électeurs très divers de groupes
sociaux très divers de signifiant gide
c'est à dire qu'on est d'attendre de
colère de demandes de deux volontés
cetera qui sont tout à fait divers et
qui sont unifiés par le discours de gaël
brustier politologue classé à gauche
parlant de maquereaux comme étant un
signifiant reid est bien dans ce
contexte ce terme signifiant reid est
une référence aux théories de la clau
c'est dire si la connaissance de leur
pensée est nécessaire pour comprendre
les débats qui animent aujourd'hui la
gauche de la gauche
mais d'abord qui sont là chloé mouche et
d'où vient-il
ernest ou
tel move sont un couple de philosophe et
chercheur en sciences politiques lui
était argentin
donc on devrait dire la cloud fait pas
la clau mais on s'en fout et elle est
belge
leur job c'est de produire des idées
sans entrer dans les détails de leur
filiation philosophique et sont
initialement issu des milieux
intellectuels marxistes la théorie de
marx partait du principe que la société
capitaliste était auto destructrice elle
crée une classe la classe ouvrière ou
prolétariat qui grossit et s'appauvrit
avec le temps et dont la lutte pour la
survie
la lutte des classes va finir par
aboutir au renversement du système et à
son remplacement par une société plus
juste
la société communiste mais l'évolution
du capitalisme va invalider ces théories
dans les années 60-70 qui sont les
années de jeunesse de laclos et bouffe
la classe ouvrière recul le secteur
tertiaire grossit et classes moyennes se
massifie et sociétés occidentales sont
de plus en plus divisé socialement et
des progrès sociaux sont apparus sans
révolution le travail étant moins
central dans la vie des gens identité et
à celui ci l'identité de classe
s'effiloche tout cela fait que
l'affrontement entre les classes central
dans la société selon marx laisse place
à d'autres identités et combats sociaux
non prévue par le marxisme des luttes
portant sur la libération des moeurs sur
les conditions de vie des luttes
écologistes pour les droits civiques ou
encore des mobilisations pacifistes et à
côté de ça pour couronner le tout on
découvre que l'urss est une dictature
est pas le paradis socialiste aurait des
pour nombre d'intellectuels marxiste
c'est la faillite totale les théories de
marx s'avèrent erronés et la révolution
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour la clau il
bouge font partie de ceux qui vont
entamer une révision de leurs théories
et c'est le marxisme de côté sans pour
autant perdre de vue la perspective de
changement social
[Musique]
laclos imhoof vend donc produire une
théorie à la fois stratégie de conquête
du pouvoir
théorie de la communication théorie
politique pensée pour un monde fragmenté
en multiples tribus identité et luttes
sectorielles
notre couple de philosophes va se dire
puisqu'il n'y a plus de classe central
chargé d'apporter progrès social mais
une multitude de petites luttes
sectorielles
il faut unir celle ci pour qu'elle
puisse au final être majoritaire mais
comment unir des luttes sans rapport les
unes avec les autres
il faut que ces luttes se sentent
solidaires et qu'elles estiment que
leurs revendications en tout la même
valeur la cloud et bouffe parle de créer
une chaîne d'équivalence entre elles
pour cela il faut un élément extérieur
qui les fédère à savoir swann d'or flou
derrière lequel chacun peut mettre ce
qu'il veut contre le gouvernement ou
pour une sixième république par exemple
soit un leader charismatique qui
cristallise tous les espoirs sur son nom
c'est le fameux signifiant lead de
galabru style en fait ce signifie envie
de 10 ou les différentes identités de
ceux qu'ils fédèrent pour créer une
nouvelle identité qui porte toutes les
revendications
c'est dans ce sens que la clause mouche
s'affirme populiste il s'agit de créer
une unité le peuple à partir de
revendication est parti donc dans cette
théorie si le populisme et de gauche il
est facteur de progrès social
ce peuple créé à partir du groupe
contestataire unifié ou alors le même
rôle que la classe ouvrière dans les
théories de marx il faut noter aussi que
dans leur logique
ce populisme permet de revigorer en
permanence la démocratie en y apportant
les aspirations populaires et ainsi de
ne pas sombrer dans une démocratie
d'experts ou de spécialistes nous faut
en particulier par de ce processus comme
d'une démocratie radicale
les dirigeants de prod et moscou ont été
les premiers à appliquer consciemment
les recettes de la clown bouffe déjà par
le choix du nom du parti podemos nous
pouvons et par le choix du loto un
simple cercle des signifiants bien vide
derrière lesquelles chacun mettra ce
qu'il voudra ensuite alors que tous les
dirigeants du parti viennent de
l'extrême gauche
la stratégie était de refuser le clivage
gauche droite et de construire à la
place une position peuple élite en
popularisant le terme de cast pour
désigner leurs adversaires de gauche
comme de droite qui ont eu le pouvoir
la filiation intellectuelle est
également clairement revendiquée puisque
inigo et les roms l'un des leaders du
mouvement ou écrit un ouvrage avec
chantôme of intitulé construire le
peuple en france mélenchon assez vite
repris le vocabulaire de podemos il
parle de caste deux peuples mais surtout
une influence de laclos et bouffe et
lisible à partir de 2016 le leader des
insoumis a commencé sa campagne
électorale pour 2010 est très tôt dès
juin 2016 avec un meeting de lancement
qui est un concentré de leur théorie
toute la première partie de ce meeting
soit 1h30 tout de même appelé défilé des
insoumis était une forme de défilé de
tous les mécontents ce qui a surpris les
journalistes
on a ainsi vu se succéder différents
secteurs en lutte cheminots personnels
hospitaliers taxi enseignants divers
militants associatifs antiraciste
féministe écolo etc tous insoumis et
bien ce défilé surprenant pour des
journalistes n'y voyant qu'une somme de
contestataires et compréhensible si on
se rappelle des théories de laclos et
bouffe tous ces mécontents sont autant
de luttes sectorielles de règlement
disperser et focaliser sur leurs
problèmes spécifiques que la france
insoumise regroupés autour de signifiant
vide des slogans axée autour du thème de
la soumission est un leader mélenchon
qui cristallise toutes les attentes
sectorielles et les unifie dans la
volonté de prendre le pouvoir
mais si cette stratégie populiste de
gauche semble avoir permis à rodez moss
de devenir la troisième force politique
du pays et semble aujourd'hui créer une
dynamique autour de jean-luc mélenchon
c'était lors ils vont pas sans poser
problème voyons lesquelles
[Musique]
le problème majeur de ces théories c'est
qu'elle fausse la perception du réel de
ceux qui les utilisent
on a l'impression de créer du neuf mais
en fait on fait qu'à billets avec de
nouveaux mots de l'ancien car si on veut
bien regarder la réalité
or des théories de la clause mouche et
bien on s'aperçoit qu'elles ne sont pas
très efficace politiquement en espagne
au demos a eu un succès incontestable
mais est ce réellement grâce à sa
stratégie
il se place hors de la gauche et de la
droite alors que les scandales de
corruption touche les deux bords tient
un discours social anti austérité dans
un pays frappé par la crise depuis 2008
avec un chômage avoisinant les 25 % et
qui en plus a connu d'importants
mouvements sociaux normal que son
discours trouve un écho d'ailleurs la
défiance envers les anciens partis
soient aussi permis un autre parti créé
après podemos appelé soudano s'était
classé au centre droit de faire lui
aussi une percée électorale en france
il nous dit qu'il ya une dynamique
autour de jean-luc mélenchon et entre 10
et 15 % dans les sondages mais ce n'est
pas exceptionnel en 2012 on a eu le même
schéma les sondages le donnaient jusqu'à
15 ou 16 % et au final il a fait 11 %
sachant que cela correspond à une
constante depuis 1995 l'extrême gauche a
toujours fait en trois disques 15% aux
présidentielles depuis cette date
la seule nouveauté est temps que depuis
2012 mélenchon phagocyte aller tout seul
cet électorat et si on veut bien
regarder le meeting de juin 2016 en du
référentiel populiste de gauche de
laclos et bouffe il n'y a rien de
nouveau
tous les insoumis qui défilent sont des
syndicalistes et des associatifs de la
gauche de la gauche fsu sud cgt parti
communiste parti de gauche
si ce populisme de gauche et peu
efficace dans la réalité
pourquoi y adhérer d'abord parce que
c'est avant tout une théorie de la
conquête du pouvoir sans contenu
programmatique
c'est un peu comme un outil marketing
qui vous laisse vous même définir le
fond idéologique de votre mouvement
ensuite pour les dirigeants de podemos
on peut avancer une explication
sociologique
la plupart des dirigeants fondateurs
sont des enseignants chercheurs en
sciences politiques
ils sont traversé sur la théorie pure et
très enclin à croire que le discours
le tout c'est une forme de déformation
professionnelle on peut au passage notez
l'ironie qu'il ya à parler du peuple
quand on a soi-même un doctorat en
sciences politiques en vue de la science
politique et qu'on fait donc partie des
personnes qui sont des experts qui
contribuent à la dépossession la
démocratie par le peuple
enfin bref passons enfin la dernière
explication c'est aussi que ces théories
permettent à la gauche de la gauche de
se renouveler théoriquement sans se
renouveler théoriquement cela permet de
changer de stratégie sans s'interroger
sur ses fondements idéologiques
il n'y a pas grand différence contre le
programme des gauches de 2012 mélenchon
et son programme populaire ou populistes
d'aujourd'hui
au final il n'est pas sûr que cette
stratégie populiste de gauche permettre
l'arrivée au pouvoir de ceux qui la
mettent en oeuvre
il faut dire qu'à mon avis la khl
bouffon commis une erreur idéologique en
élaborant leurs théories pour élaborer
leurs théories laclos et bouffon étudié
différents mouvements taxé de populisme
pour en tirer un schéma général et pour
créer ce schéma général qu'ils ont mis
de côté le contenu politique de ses
mouvements et leur contexte historique
mais en politique peut-on expliquer la
genèse d'un mouvement hors de son
contexte peut-on trouver un schéma
valables en tout temps et en tout lieu
pour expliquer des processus hautement
soumis à des contextes historiques et
sociaux à mon avis c'est un non sens
total
c'est comme si je vous disais pour faire
un bon parti politique il faut un leader
un slogan un logo un programme des
militants c'est un schéma général hors
contexte qui dit tout et rien à la fois
il n'est pas faux mais il n'explique en
rien la naissance d'un parti dans un
contexte historique ni comment faire un
parti qui fonctionne c'est tout le
problème de cette théorie anhistorique
est apolitique
on peu calqué son jargon sur à peu près
toutes les structures partisanes et
avoir l'impression d'avoir créé un
mouvement populaire alors qu'en fait on
ajustera semblait sa propre famille
politique
résultat on se retrouve avec la france
insoumise hégémonique à la gauche de la
gauche mais qui au final a peu de
chances d'arriver au pouvoir
et bien voilà cette vidéo est terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous aura apporté des
éléments pour comprendre les théories
sur le populisme de laclos et mof
qu'inspire notamment jean luc mélenchon
je vous donne rendez vous dans une
prochaine vidéo et c'est là je vous dis
portez vous bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]